so good afternoon my name is Randy and
I'm here with my fellow Joshua we'd like
to present you the data modelling
processing on travel super app so
a bit but tray loca so our mission is
we're trying to empower discovery means
we'd like to enrich people's life by
giving a possible opportunities to kind
of like do some activities or
attractions going to new places meeting
new people so this is where we kind of
like have a vision at and probably in
order to know what our challenges would
like to explain our business first so
these are our businesses so imagine if
you are going from one city to another
and you would like to for example book a
flight ticket and book a hotel ticket
and there you might want to experience
some new activities so we provide all of
them and our challenges here is each of
the business units actually have their
own business flow so if you would like
to book a hotel compared to when you
book a flight of the forum or the
information that you need to provide to
the app is kind of like different right
even it's more different compared to for
example a roaming package so it's of the
business have their own characteristic
and it's quite different from one to
another so that's the the characteristic
of the business that we have yeah a bit
more about travel oka we are expanding
to six countries now more most of them
are in so this Asia we have eight
offices including Singapore so so what
are our challenges actually there are
two challenge that we'd like to share
today in this occasion the first one is
data modelling silo and the second one
is dirty data so what is silo as I
explained before truffle oka has several
businesses or service or product and
each of the businesses here has their
own characteristic and what we try to
start in the beginning is will try to
democratize data wrangling or data
processing why we want to democratize
that it's just natural to democratize
that because it means each of the
business unit can be more agile to fit
the business purpose right so that's
what we did
however
they kind of like crane create their own
data model their own data that can
support like insights or maybe
missionary pipelines and what we have
end up is in in each of the basis unit
the data model is actually quite
different from one to another and one
the most challenge with that different
data model from one business unit to
another is it's very hard to unless data
across business unit so who's our most
actually when we have different data
from one product to another the biggest
challenge is on those functions so when
we have a function that is actually
cross all products they need to analyze
data cross position its right so when
they need to know it up from liver and
business unit they need to kind of like
make it uniform first in their side and
after they make it uniform then they run
their analysis this is a very first very
exhaustive step and second is also very
expensive and imagine if each of the
basis are sorry the function also that's
the same so it's a kind of like a
problem I put one business example here
let's say we would like to know CLV or
customer lifetime value the simplest way
to do is just to kind of like sum or
profit from the customer that we have
but since we have different sales data
in each of the businesses it's very hard
to do so and how do we solve this data
seller we come up with some kind of like
generic schema so it's very natural
you have different data than you would
try to enforce some kind of like
convention right so that what we did we
kind of like design a generic schema
across the business unit so this is how
you need to comply with like for example
a very simple as a simple example is if
you have a sales data and at least it
has an order ID date/time etc but then
how the next occasion is how you can
ensure that that convention is being
implemented in each of the product or
services there are two options actually
that we have first is let's say we have
a console of reviewer so there are perks
example group of reviewer
that each of the business unit can
propose their data model and then
someone approve where there is complete
a convention or not but that's manual
process and actually error-prone so we
come up with a framework so the remote
that I'm talking about is a schema
inheritance concept where we have so
this inheritance concept is actually
concept that is quite simple and applied
in several domain like for example in
object-oriented programming the concept
is there is a parent and the parent has
its properties and it has a child and
the child will inherit all properties
from the parents as simple as that and
the central theme in this case will
divine the parent schema and each of the
business unit will be the child of that
schema and automatically will comply to
the convention this is one one very
simple example we put one inheritance
tree here in the very up there
will have an all event schema in this
all event schema the columns are any
columns that has to exist in all event
data entry of loka let's take one is a
simple example like even ID or x time
that that has to be there the child of
the element schemas user behavior schema
in this user behavior schema will have
more information about our user like
user ID setting in their apps or like
language locale something like that and
the child of the user behavior is each
of the events in this example I put a
sales product schema which is child of
user behavior the circle one in that
diagram is schemas and this the
rectangle one is the tables so let's
let's take one example like in the
flight sales table we might we the table
will have the column from all event user
behavior and cells so it's kind of like
try to enforce the convention based on
the inheritance schema that we have here
and in this example a flight and hotel
sales table will have common columns for
example if in the sales product schema
maybe there will be revenue column or
profit column and reddit so it's kind of
like an for so it's uniform across the
business unit yeah this is just one real
example on the whole event schema user
settings and cell schema what are the
fields that actually there and it's kind
of like inherited from its grand
grandparent to the great-grandson so a
bit of a pic on the implementation we
use llamo Yama is kind of like similar
to Jason it's just a way to express the
schema so if you see here the parent a
flight search Jamal and the bottom it
has the apparent user behavior and the
user behaviors appeared as all event and
our frameworks kind of like resolve
recursively into the parent so after we
make the table uniform across all
business unit to answer the example
equation that I've put in the front is a
simple as this you can just select group
by and from actually I'm using a big
query dialect here I think it should be
similar in order of antivirus appliance
this the starts there is Union all all
tables with the same prefix so when we
Union all tables from all the business
unit this is how we do that yeah so
that's about that model silo and now the
next one is about dirty data and when we
talk about dirty data again the problem
statement that we have is each of the
position it have their own processing
right and when we observe there are many
duplicated effort that has been done in
each of the processing and we see that
dirty data is one of them and when we
check the pattern most of the patterns
actually most about business rule like
maybe whether it's kind of like in the
range of minimum X or maximum or whether
the string pattern is something that is
acceptable or excess or expected or not
and what are the possible value is very
simple if you have a status the possible
values should usually finit and view
right there might be data that is kind
of
like outside that possible values and
it's repeated process I think that's
clear and now how we fix the situation
is so as I explained before we have a
kind of like schema to explain the
parent-child relationship right so we
put a business throw there as well
we put business role there in this case
I put several example first it's the
pattern there it's kind of sketchy ugly
wrex so if you have a pair version and
this is actually just mentok versioning
pattern reg X you can check whether the
data that is coming is actually comply
to this reg reg patterns or not
another example is maximum and minimum
value of an integer and several possible
values are of our booking status so
imagine you don't have to implement
those codes and you can write once and
use everywhere and the most important
thing I think is the concept of
executable schema where several role in
data team can collaborate together so we
don't have any other documentation than
this description of data is there
this is role is there so that the
governor analytics business owner
everyone is kind of like elaborating the
same document so the idea of this
executable spec is actually quite quite
interesting so yeah that's about the
dirty data we call this framework as
neon DDL we are not good at naming but
yeah it's kind of like just a new of
normally deal thing of create table
comment it's just a simple llamo it's
support inheritance and we put some
business row there and maybe some more
features like they will tell you I
haven't put it here but actually it also
integrated out that with our data
catalog system so the description that
has been put in this schema will be sent
over data catalog and can be seen
directly on the table description and
also searchable by the analyst and
scientist so yeah no I think just so
we'll explain more about implementation
detail so you get more attention thank
you
okay Thank You Randy so now you already
know what are the features and usage of
the Neo DDL so now I'll talk about how
is New Deal being utilized in our data
processing flow currently it is
currently being used in our data
warehouse pipeline I'll agree I'll give
you a brief overview on our data
warehouse architecture your nutshell you
can see in our slides it combines the
multi-layer architecture with the data
warehouse bus approach by ralph kimball
where each business units has its own
confirmed dimension or that data Mart
and together they form the bigger data
warehouse I will explain more on this on
a later slide most of the data are
collected and stored in the bigquery and
each layer here from l1 to l5 will have
increasing data quality and they also
have different data green granularity
you can see l1 and l2 can be considered
as data staging area where error
discovery data structuring or data
masking are being performed l3 and l4 is
a model data area where the data is
modeled according to the common business
process for example order sales or
refund so the only difference between l3
and l4 is that l4 is the aggregated
version of l3 can be aggregated based on
time for example weekly monthly or
yearly or aggregated horizontally across
business process to calculate for
example confessionary okay so obviously
since the deal is in the name neo DDL is
currently being used to define the
schema and also to create all the tables
in l2 and l4 since you are following
dimensional modeling described by Kimbo
most of the tables that we have in l2
and l4 are either facts or dimensions
I'm not going to dig deeper on what
factional dimension is
but essentially facts are a collection
of events that happens in our
application and the dimensions are
accompanying detail of that events for
example a fact can be a flight sales
booking and a dimension can be a user or
a device that have an attribute such as
operation or device type and what is
what is what's interesting is since you
are using bigquery and bigquery allows
nested data structure naturally we want
to embed that dimension into effect
tables instead of having a separate
dimension table so this is where new ETL
comes to shine using the inheritance
feature that Randy has mentioned just
now it becomes much easier to define the
embedded dimension structure that will
be used for all business units so one
example like Randy mentioned previously
we have schema called user behavior this
user behavior actually contains some
dimension one of it is user dimension
and also a device dimension so if a
business units wants to have this
dimension inside their FAQ tables what
they need to do is just inherit those
user behavior schema and their fact
table will automatically be embedded
with this user dimension and device
dimension so it is okay
so it ensures that all business units
will have the same dimension structure
and this way we get the increased
performance from the nested data
structure because we will have less
joints but we'll we can also still
enforce the dimension structure across
business units another part where we use
neo DDL is during the cleansing job in
data flow so remember that water Andy
said previously in each field we can
have a simple business role validation
so each of this rule plus some other
village validations specific to that
business units will be converted into
individual step in the data flow job by
the way data flow is just a managed
version of Apache beam from DCP so in
addition not only we have consistent
structure but all the business units can
can expect if they have the same
dimension same field name that field
will undergo the same business cleansing
room so as you can see on the left we
have a sample of neo DDL and for force
for each other business rule will
convert it into individual step in the
deployed job on the right I'll explain
to you some of the simple business rule
that we do on data flow first is just a
simple casting we will try to cast the
content and then if it is custom to the
specified type we will continue the
validation if not we will ignore that
that field and we will check the record
and provide the default value you might
think that well casting should be easy
right and it should be enforced on the
sale product side but since some of our
source might have a weak data type
consistency for let's say the sum of our
products are still using MongoDB it's
become a problem because when we
we are actually getting just a JSON
string and MongoDB doesn't really
enforce the data type so we are we are
actually doing the enforcement on our
data site and also why tech the data
instead of removing the dirty record
well it is simply because different
end-user has different tolerance to
their so the data flow job
responsibilities here it's actually just
on error discovery some users might have
low tolerance to error or they might be
just want to have one to analyze that
error records so there are correction
and mitigation will only happen on a
subsequent layer or as needed by the end
user
next is just the the string validation
we have the min max and pattern quite
obvious here we will do the error
tagging and some simple string
transformation which is padding and
truncation we did this because we find
this pattern across business units and
there's just a requirement we have next
is the numeric numeric validation this
is just minimax value there is no data
transformation will be done here just
error tagging by the way I will explain
more about error taking after this next
is the enumeration quite obvious and the
now check type we will just see what
which field is declared as required and
if there's any null value will give a
default value on that field so what does
error taking looks like in our data
warehouse basically all our of our
tables in the de warehouse has a column
called DPE
VP is just an internal code name for our
project and E is error
it is basically a repeat repeated field
that contains three fill error message
ETL name and class in error message you
can see in the slides
it shows explanation of what rule has
been violated and by which field the ETL
name shows which ETL catches this
violation and the class does show which
Python class that is responsible for
validating the for validating and
producing the error message so we can
imagine that one one record can have
multiple violation inside and we combine
them together in this repeated fields so
on the top records you can see that it
is just a casting failure the provider
hotel ID just expect a number but
instead it has a string inside and there
there's a lot of interesting stuff that
can be found just by looking at this
error message as you can see in the
middle the payment meta is now which is
unfortunate because this record might be
a fraud but not all it's unfortunate
because if you see on a bottom example
we have a user payment status which is
actually overpaid so in this case thank
you yes
yeah by the way this is what we retrieve
directly from our booking table and here
are some more examples with our records
the top is the top example is just a
string form an error where the ID
expects minimum of three three strings
and then we just do some simple data
data padding and some more interesting
findings that we found also in the error
taking is that we have a validation or
each flight ticket booking we have we
need to have at least one adult but what
we found in some booking is actually we
have zero adults
so in this case what a brave young soul
so we have some future plan that we
think is going to be beneficial for our
business site first is to add more
business metadata for data cataloging
you see if you see the slides this will
be really beneficial if we know who are
the business expert for the table and
for each column we can also tag who is
the column owner and a business expert
and not just inside the table but we are
also trying to add a metadata on a data
model relationship so for example we can
take a field as a foreign key and we can
define what is the target table for that
foreign key it can enables us to
automatically generate a star schema
diagram like you see on the right the
flight search is affect Able's and
category suppliers and order details are
the dimensions they can be from in our
tables but they can also be embedded
inside the fact table itself so the
ability to create automatic star schema
diagram will be really useful for for
the engineers as well so thank you
that's all and any questions
hello yeah hi so my question is that you
said that you will be expanding in more
countries recently uh in recent future
so this is kind of a centralized
database where you bring all the
businesses together so as you expand in
new countries will have more dirty data
right and which will require more
collaboration and the mature nurse or
the business might not be the same as
older countries from day one so in that
case how do you think what are the kind
of challenges you will face and how we
solve them so yeah this is actually
quite interesting in some cases it's
it's more about string.format like maybe
in some countries they're using the
Auvergne different alphabet rights so we
sometimes there are problems there
however when we expand into new
countries actually the pattern is not
that you learn it's merely about adding
new value in the dimension and
differences of the data is not that much
because it's like a very similar
business just new country I think the
only thing that we found so far when
expanding to six countries just
difference in the field value especially
in text okay just a follow-up question
say for example you're expanding to a
new country which has a new currency so
all your every numbers will report it a
new currency now so then how do you
manage updating each and every time and
when would you know when to update your
patterns in checks for that part
actually we kind of like convert
everything to USD so yeah so it's not in
each of the currency it's kind of like
all convert that USD so thank you
good talk thank you I can see how you're
the Neo DDL can is gonna work for the
event type data are you using a similar
tool or the same tool for like your um
slower moving data from databases as
well like are you are you duplicating
the schema to some extent from Postgres
or my sequel or whatever to your llamo
definition yeah so the answer is it's
depends so it's it has several variants
in our observations in some cases in the
ends the data that is coming from the
mutable data is actually we transfer it
into something immutable like for
example there are order data and the
order is kind of like changing from one
status to another we can of capture the
status changes and make it like them so
in this case it becomes similar however
there are some catches as well where
it's more make sense to kind of have
glossary instead of inheritance for
example if you would like to enforce one
single term is being used across the
company and there is no ambiguity on
that
so actually we also have developed
something that's similar to that
internally or we called it mixin it's
kind of like a business closer II for a
business but yeah I think that's we can
discuss that more later but in the end
what we do is when we take data from
databases we try to extract the event
because we'd like to put it on the
effect table right so we need to be
millimeter ball so it's 42
oh nothing yeah thank you
[Applause]